doit il donne même entendement du
renouvellement le funiculaire de la
butte montmartre a disparu depuis le 1er
octobre des anges de démolition ont rasé
cette installation mise en place en 1934
à la place le 1er juin prochain
des cabines de métal satiné
transporteront des voyageurs ils étaient
deux millions et demi l'an dernier en
attendant il faut monter à pied ou en
bus dominique chappuit et lydie monnaie
et alors les escaliers sont pas trop
difficiles il amène en dissidence à dieu
c'est pour resserrer quel jeu mende -
c'est pour dieu comprenait encore huit
mois de patience le nouveau funiculaire
de montmartre ne sera mis en service que
le 1er juin prochain l'ancien système
installé en 1934 n'arrivait plus à
absorber le flux croissant des touristes
la ratp a donc décidé de faire table
rase du passé
les nouvelles cabines pour monter et
descendre en même temps et il suffira de
70 secondes pour atteindre les premières
marches du sacré coeur en attendant il
faut grimper et il n'y a pas que les
rivera qui peine parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de marches à monter pour les ventes et
pour les liaisons douces y a pas besoin
des comptes on sait déjà combien m pour
éviter cet exercice trop répétées aux
habitants de la butte le service de bus
a été doublé aujourd'hui les
montmartrois attendent avec impatience
le nouveau funiculaire ils ont enterré
le dernier sans nostalgie
j'aurais préféré une gare rétro qui
aurait été peut-être mieux dans le cadre
de montmartre mais puisque ce n'est pas
possible le pécuniairement parlant
paraît-il
et soyons fous futur est finalement les
seuls qui regretteront le funiculaire ce
sont les touristes mais il leur reste
les cartes postales
soyez